viva la I've killed seven people  torture them an unspeakable way so he  ascends I ask an absolution something  has happened to my husband he went to  the store but he never came home  have you heard about this Gemini killer  no he always answers his phone he'd find  a widow that was an interesting tattoo  Gemini it's way  a very docile  difficult would it be to not gather to  think enamel would be loud okay I'm  sorry  no there we go everything yes his name  is Craig oh it means just check again  right now forgive us our trespasses as  we forgive those who have trespassed  against us that's what you see on the  outside not what's on the inside I smile  all the time  they're doing bad things  you